Last year's winner was Alexandra
[inaudible] from Dublin.
He was 15 when he won the competition
with his work on tennis sensor data
analysis.
But it didn't stop there.
I was doing a,
Sullivan has been finding out
seating at the bt young scientists
competition is all about hard work and
no one exemplifies this more.
And last year's winner Alexander,
I'm Mimi,
he arrived in Ireland from New York,
but he's found he just two years ago
quickly set his sights on the
competition.
It was a really something that came to
me like overnight because uh,
I play a lot of tennis and it was just
the idea of trying to create a system to
help tennis players because coaching can
be so expensive.
It's something that is a such a luxury
for tennis athletes.
So to have something like a program that
can provide real time feedback,
unbiased feedback to an athlete in real
time is just a necessity for every time
I sit down.
Alexander has been playing from a very
early age,
so it probably wasn't surprising he
chose to incorporate in this project.
Um,
my whole family faced this actually.
So I have two sisters and one brother.
We all play tennis.
My Dad started us,
uh,
to play tennis and he's been all of our
coach.
Uh,
so my project is just a motion
refinement and recognition system.
So I turned my projects for tennis and
specific.
But what it does is just recognized as
the type of motions that a athlete or a
person is performing and then tries to
provide feedback on how to improve these
motions.
Alexandre use the facilities here at
tennis Ireland in Dcu for his project as
their courts can be filmed from several
different angles from cameras located
high on the walls.
Alexandra use the raw data from tennis
sessions,
played here to write his own computer
program which can interpret how good
your tennis swing is from the signal
sent from a motion sensor worn on the
wrist.
He used 13 different computer languages
to write the software and unsurprisingly
wild the judges,
the bt young scientists and
technologists.
I'll the year 2011
is it
Alexander?
This I have to say is well,
the best ones we've ever seen at a
working level in terms of research.
This is an excellent project compared to
a an honors undergraduate degree level
or even postgraduate degree level
research project.
Um,
he has taken a very complex problem,
is applied very complicated techniques
to try and solve the problem and he's
brought it to completion.
It's a really good piece of work
and it has an immediate practical
application.
As a tennis coach myself,
it's fantastic
to have this tool to m to use with
tennis players to help them develop
their strokes and to to analyze this
rogue.
So it's,
it's,
it's an incredible discovery was done
very well with a chair.
Of course it didn't end there.
Alexandra is project was automatically
entered into the European Union contest
for young scientists and again,
won first prize.
There's four or five days and I think
the,
the atmosphere in the exhibition was
also incredible because you have top
competitors,
they're winners of their national
competition all coming together to
compete.
Again,
that is just being recognized for
something like that.
You pour your heart and soul into,
uh,
working on it.
So constantly to be recognized for
something like that is just a huge
honor.
Of course,
everyone at his school in Castle,
not college,
couldn't be brighter from the first
arrived until this very moment.
He's been just tough class,
an absolutely excellent student,
very dedicated.
He said to me on the first day,
uh,
when he wants to do the young scientist
project,
so I'm going to win it.
And he won it.
I started to laugh but I shouldn't have.
But a very dedicated,
he doesn't sleep.
He works and Works and works.
Nobody asked it,
realizes how hard he works,
give her a rising tides,
lift all boats.
And uh,
the entry this year we have never had
more interest into the young scientists
at all sorts.
Increase the uptake of science subjects
biology with three classes to leave us
or biology.
The hard work hasn't ended for Alexandra
though.
He skipped a school year in order to do
the leaving cert early this July and
he's continuing to develop this project.
I've have two patents on my project and
I hope to develop it further in the
coming months and years.
It's applicable to tennis,
but also a wide range of other fields.
So I'd love to start testing on things
like medical applications and sports
rehabilitation,
medical rehabilitation,
and things like this.
I think it has much more often
something like tennis.
Congratulations once again to Alexander,
and we wish them the very best for the
future.